across the country there is a growing
darkness a belief that the end of days
is near i'm preparing my family for the
total destruction of the power grid the
yellowstone super volcano a financial
collapse [ __ ] load
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare when survival is
the goal it's into the spider hole and
protect themselves go fast fast fast
fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
i'm gonna use like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans
what we've got here is 50 000 pounds and
it'll last two people for 20 years gone
to great lengths i eat what most people
would call weeds and made huge personal
sacrifices to ensure their very survival
but you know what
when it hits the fan she's gonna starve
to death and i'm gonna go
experts will assess their extreme preps
and decide if they have what it takes to
face armageddon we built our house out
of 40-foot steel shipping containers and
to survive
this is doomsday preppers
paul range is retired from his corporate
job and lives with his wife gloria
outside of floresville texas
they enjoy eating barbecue with friends
relaxing on their back porch
and
preparing for the end of the world as we
know it
let's go let's go we're bugging out
i'm a prepper because i'm preparing for
when it's the fan what we've got here is
about 50 000 pounds and it'll last two
people for
20 years
paul and gloria consider prepping for
the apocalypse a full-time job
they dedicate 50 hours a week to storing
food
building up defenses and designing
gadgets all to improve their chance of
survival after the end of days it's not
a hobby it's a lifestyle it's just in me
i don't know how to live any different
let's get going this sunday is no
different
a normal retiree activity like playing
golf is not on the agenda
instead they are testing the strength of
their home against incoming gunfire i
don't need mine as big because i hit
better
that's bad by shooting live rounds at
the walls this test is necessary to find
out
how effective
the house is against small arms fire
with the town of san antonio only 35
miles away
they fear that the end of the world will
bring desperate and armed civilians to
their doorstep people will show up and
want food and you cannot feed the entire
world
so we want a full hundred yards and
that's gonna be right out here to
simulate civilian fire they are testing
the 22 22-caliber rifle one of the most
common guns in america
okay weapon's hot
commits firing
dead-on it went through it i heard it
and that 3-8 steal the result of this
test whether a bullet will go through
the wall or not could mean the
difference between life and death for
those inside a house under siege
hopefully we won't have new holes in the
house
yeah we got uh one round here one around
here one round here one round here just
a slight bend
the test is a success
okay
some people would think that this was um
not normal behavior but it gives a whole
lot of peace of mind that rounds are not
going to be going completely through
i haven't been crawling crazy to my face
except for a couple of my kids you know
that doesn't worry me i mean this is the
lifestyle that we live and if people
don't like it they don't have to come on
the property
all of paul and gloria's preps are in
readiness for one extreme worldwide
event
a complete magnetic polar shift we are
seeing an increase
of earthquakes um that i think are
probably associated with some earth
changes
scientists agree that the earth's north
and south magnetic poles are constantly
moving location by up to 25 miles a year
and every 300 000 years or so prehistory
has shown that they will actually switch
completely
the last polar shift occurred 780 000
years ago leading some people to believe
we're overdue for a global flip-flop
that could have devastating consequences
the worst case would be a massive
earthquake type thing where the
continents did a fast shift most all the
buildings would fall down and collapse
paul believes that a polar shift will
also cause the continent's land masses
to shift north and south along the
earth's mantle
potentially moving antarctica towards
the equator and texas towards canada the
earthquakes have been stepping up lately
and by next year i'm thinking the
rattling will continue and intensify
everybody should be prepared
a typical house would be no match
against the devastation paul and gloria
fear so they built their very own
doomsday fortress the range compound
we built our house out of nine 40-foot
steel shipping containers
they are designed to carry about 58 000
pounds each
and be stacked eight high so that's an
incredible half million pounds of weight
that these things can sustain
shipping containers are normally used to
transport tons of commercial goods
across the ocean but recently their
ability to withstand heavy abuse and
their low cost around four thousand
dollars each has made them a desired
building material for dedicated preppers
essentially i'm in a welded steel box so
i'm not worried about my container
shifting in an earthquake
when i walked up to it the first time it
was just
wow this is really something we've done
we have
a structure that totally houses that
will totally feed us
and totally protect us the compound is
based on the layout of a medieval castle
a square fort that encloses a safe
courtyard and allows them 360 degrees of
protection
from the ground we can see about 800
yards in every direction from the roof
we can see about two miles
so we have clear fields of fire for out
to a thousand meters so that gives us an
area that we can see people that we can
see predators
but they cannot protect the compound
against everything
some believe a continental shift could
potentially move texas to a different
point on the globe completely changing
the climate if we shift north winters
are going to be harsher we have to
assume
that we're going to have crop failures
the prospect of a future without readily
available food drives paul and gloria to
cook not three but eight meals a day
allowing them to put aside enough food
each week to survive an extra 11
post-apocalyptic days what kind of
chicken you're making the chimichanga
base oh chingachanga base
and we're gonna can that yep the 25
pounds of chicken they preserve today
has enough protein to sustain four
people for six days we're preparing for
family and friends we're not just
preparing for the two of us
gloria's favorite doomsday candy is made
from fresh corn dehydrated so it can
last for over a decade dried corn is a
very good morale booster and treat food
it's extremely sweet kids eat it just
like candy eight gallons of fresh corn
dehydrates into a one gallon jar so two
weeks supply for four people
and at night
the day's hunt is butchered so it can be
smoked and stored this dough could
potentially feed 22 people for a week
all of their food is added to
the pantry
a container with a 58 000 pound capacity
and right now they're running out of
space
i would say we have in excess of fifty
thousand pounds of food
corn worth seven hundred
in this room it's our main pantry and we
have everything starting with pastas
wet canned goods spices
fema guidelines suggest that three days
worth of food should be stored in your
home in case of a disaster
for paul and gloria that is just a drop
in the bucket we could make it for 15
years for 22 people
but back here in the cans they have the
20-year shelf life or more right
food storage was like an insurance
policy we figured that our food has
actually gained 400 in value since we
started so instead of investing in a
401k that just now lost 27 000 in the
last three weeks we have actually gained
in value of 400 percent so for me that's
a good investment
paul believes that a rapid continental
shift would cause earthquakes that will
knock out the electrical grid
and rupture gas lines
so after the day's food preps are
complete he spends up to seven hours a
day working on alternative sources of
energy
when the grid goes down i just flip a
switch and we're in power this machine
on the roof called an upwind machine
you're putting out about 650 of the 750
watts that the machine is capable of of
handling paul has built and installed a
system of small windmills and solar
panels making the compound capable of
being completely independent of the
national grid instead of having one huge
solar panel array and one huge wind
generator we've opted to spread that out
so if i have a wind generator failure
it's not going to affect
my entire system wind and solar are just
two ways that paul worked to doomsday
proof his energy
the third way
is just as effective
but not quite as clean the methane is
run by the pig poop
and actually our poop too
methane is a highly flammable gas
produced from human and animal waste
sewer line comes in from the house and
then from the pig pen and in to the
methane bio digester
despite its origins methane is actually
an odorless gas
this gives us a cooking fuel that is not
a wood product in the case that the flag
went up and society went to hell you
could smell wood smoke from several
miles away and i don't want to be that
person that's burning that wood smoke
the structure is actually taking care of
me
we're prepared here we have water we
have food we have means to grow things
we have our animals here we have all the
power requirements that we want i can
get a good night's sleep knowing that
i'm protected within these walls
paul and gloria have built a prepper's
paradise that they believe will see them
through 15 years of hell on earth
but if staying put becomes too dangerous
they also have a plan b that will take
their prepping to a whole new extreme
paul range and his wife gloria haswell
are convinced that the world's
continental land masses will soon shift
north or south along the earth's mantle
causing catastrophic earthquakes that
will flatten our cities
and crush our infrastructure
even if we shifted two or three degrees
it would still throw everything in the
chaos
there will be a series of devastating
earthquakes and i just want to be ready
determined to face the apocalypse with
reinforcements paul and gloria have
picked a team of 22 friends and family
who will live and fight alongside them
we're just going to do a little target
shooting and a little range safety today
some of the team assembles at the range
compound to hone their prepping skills
and solidify their plans
all right make yourself ready load
range is going hot fire one ready
the time that i realized
that i needed to prep
was in vietnam
i was there in 1975 when it fell
the chaos was just unbelievable
i just don't want to be stuck in that
type of situation
you may fire it well
so because of our military experience we
leaned a little heavier toward
military type
we have probably three quarters that a
marksman
i was a marine in his army
yeah for both grunts
i was on iraq
there's no infrastructure at all it's
gone down all right show me the weapon i
don't like being helpless and now i feel
good because i have a plan good job
stevie boy and i feel prepared
38 not really there are some couples
there are some with kids
move to wherever you're comfortable at
go to town the children are the future
excellent form all right shotgun boy
and the nice thing is that uh children
growing up in that type of environment
are not going to really know anything
else
but building stocking and manning a
bulletproof compound is not enough for
paul and gloria like many preppers they
want the complete insurance of a plan b
our goal uh no matter what happens um
except for in the in the case of
something really extreme happening is to
actually stay in place but if we had to
we could uproot and operate really
quickly let's get going let's get moving
in case the range compound is
compromised they have formulated an
extensive evacuation plan a bug out that
will take the entire team to a second
location 12 hours north
and today they will test it out
we're running a drill to make sure that
we can load up in under an hour
and bug out they will drive specially
customized bug out vehicles
second hand school buses we've got a
house sitting on wheels
we took all the seats but a few out we
have a way for at least four to six
people to sleep
within the confines of the vehicle
paul knows from vietnam that being able
to bug out quickly could mean the
difference between life and death
timing is everything all right guys we
have uh 55 minutes to get the bus loaded
up let's get going
those cans those cans
their aim today is to leave the compound
with their animals approximately 10 000
pounds of food and 310 gallons of water
in under an hour let's put these boxes
over here the tail gunner's gonna be
there all right let me have the carbine
please
and we're gonna lean the carbine in the
corner we believe that we can survive
for about 10 years with what we're going
to take with us
come on goats we're bugging out
our animals are actually trained
to bug out come on
come on goats
hurry hurry hurry
you're gonna get left behind
we've got water we've got food and
kitchen equipment we've got the medical
supply we're ready to go all right guys
let's get going
go go go go
let's go let's go
pulling out
the convoy of buses will travel to a
pre-designated safe point two and a half
hours from the compound
from there they will go on to their
final and secret destination
we have a specific time of the day
that we are going to leave because we
want to move through some areas in the
dark and we want to move through some
areas in the daylight we can get to
anywhere within the state without having
to actually pass through a big city
a school bus was actually designed to
roll over and everybody inside come out
intact
when we feel that we need to pull over
for the night then we are going to
actually circle the wagons
the pioneers going across this country
circled their wagon for extremely valid
reason by replicating the pioneers and
creating a square with four bug out
vehicles paul's team can spend the night
in the safe central haven defend it on
all sides
with a minimum of four guards you have a
defensive position
paul and gloria's team have successfully
bugged out to their save points within
the appointed time
we can be really proud of the fact
that that plan worked i knew you could
do a good job
i think that you need to be responsible
for yourself and for your family and to
do anything less is a criminal act
the experts in disaster preparedness
practical preppers have concluded that
you have multiple sources of water
and extensive food stores and that your
home defense and emergency evacuation
plans are excellent
also your energy and fuel alternatives
are exceptional you have an overall
fantastic level of preparedness
however keeping your 15-year food supply
in one area is a grave risk leaving you
vulnerable to losing it all with one
direct hit or one strong attack that's a
fair assessment that would be a good
idea to diversify the food into multiple
locations our thought on that was that
probably if our food supply was
compromised by us being overrun this
position we wouldn't really care at that
point because we'd be dead
since the original filming we have added
several things in reference to splitting
up our food storage we have actually
stored a little bit more food within our
bug out vehicles and we do have caches
along the way of our bug-out route so
that's some of the things that we've
actually changed
christopher niergash is prepping for a
killer earthquake that could completely
flatten the city of los angeles
faced with overwhelming destruction he
plans on taking to the hollywood streets
foraging to survive but will the experts
be impressed by his lone wolf approach
[Music]
christopher niergesch runs several
farmers markets and teaches grows his
own food and loves to hike in the hills
around la he's a regular down to earth
californian
except i'm preparing for the possibility
of a devastating earthquake in the city
of los angeles
it would be the height of stupidity to
be aware of earthquakes and watch the
news and see what happens and not make
some preparations
i live here in southern california this
is earthquake country
the san andreas fault runs like an 800
mile long scarred down the western coast
of the united states and mexico
it's up to a mile across and at least 10
miles deep
a gigantic earthquake along this fault
line would rip the state of california
apart
some people do say we're past due for an
eight on the richter scale which would
be devastating in the next 30 years
geologists believe that the probability
of a major 6.7 or higher earthquake in
southern california is nearly 100
a truly massive quake could kill
thousands and leave millions homeless
what do you think the scenario would be
in los angeles
for example today when the lakers win a
game the local thugs are burning cars
and breaking into windows and looting
stores to celebrate
major quake will bring panicked chaotic
behavior by people
christopher's plan after a quake
includes being able to survive under the
radar on the chaotic city streets
everybody has a different take on what
they think preparedness is if somebody
likes to hole up in a place and hide i
believe that that is the antithesis of
survival you've got to split you can't
stay there you have to be on the road
christopher regularly tests his street
survival skills right in the middle of
the concrete jungle his only supplies
those he can carry in his bag most
people call this a bug out pack but i
just refer to it as a survival pack
tools are what's important this is from
a chainsaw the wire saws in the
backpacking stores are junk oh a sling
there are birds and ducks and things and
if i had to potentially i could catch
some meat for dinner with my sling a
knife
can never have enough knives
i have never seen a survival kit
manufactured that i liked
some twine because it's made with
somebody else's needs in mind you are
the best person for making your own
survival kit you know what your needs
are your family's needs your terrain
what your situation is going to be
if there was a major quake there's quite
a few things that will happen
simultaneously electricity is going to
go down every transaction is electronic
you won't go to a store and be able to
buy stuff certainly not with a card it
behooves you to have cash and coin on
hand
along the la river the homeless guys who
come here at night are very territorial
so you may have to engage in some
serious trading
so one of the things that i suggest
carrying in a survival pack like this is
articles of trade these are a roll of
eisenhower dollars so people will treat
this as if it's worth more than a dollar
when they want cash but christopher is
also prepping for a time when his cash
runs out and he will have to be able to
trade and barter to survive homemade
arrow points it could be used for making
arrows they could be articles of trade
under certain circumstances they are
intrinsically useful
a massive earthquake in l.a could
decimate highways and limit supply lines
christopher believes that food will be
in short supply
he prepares regularly foraging for his
food in the parking lots and concrete
underpasses around the city
a lot of the greens that i eat for salad
or additions to soup and vegetable
dishes
they are what what most people would
call weeds
we're along the la river and we've got a
freeway next to us
and you'd think that there's no food
here at all
but the fact is there really is food
everywhere food is not in short supply
it's uh brains that are in short supply
here's one example of an edible plant
it's called lambsquarter or wild spinach
frequently i'll go out and we'll find
greens and we'll make a salad in the
wild i'm going to take just a few of the
tips for a lunch later
[Music]
in just a two acre area christopher has
foraged 10 different plants that can be
used to make his salad
just chopping it all into bite-size
pieces
my survival kit usually has salad
dressing
[Music]
one of my motivating reasons for getting
into botany in the first place was that
if there was a widespread disaster i
could eat
i know that i'm never going to be hungry
for the rest of my life because there's
plenty of food everywhere even if there
are no stores
[Music]
if the big one hits the city's hospitals
could be severely damaged understaffed
and overflowing with patients
christopher's botanical skills allow him
to treat wounds with just what he can
find growing in the city the willow tree
is found everywhere where there's water
see this is a medicinal plant when you
take off the fresh bark their cambium
layer contains a high amount of salicin
or salicylic acid that's aspirin what if
i get into a knife fight what if i had a
wound on my arm you don't want
infections you want to stop the bleeding
make it a little bit moist
press it onto a wound and i would bind
this on tightly onto the wound and leave
it there for a while to get the effect
of the aspirin or the salicylic acid
settling down for the night in the
dangerous and quake devastated city
means being able to light a fire fire is
as critical and i could even argue
more critical than food
i can remember going into the woods with
book matches and stick matches and in
the rain and in the wet and the cold
that's just not good enough
christopher carries fire starters at all
times and can even create a fire using
just scraps
the hand drill method uses a stick to
create friction and sparks in a notch of
soft wood in the old days when native
americans left home like we might leave
home and you can't leave home without
your credit card and your cell phone
they had to have some kind of a knife in
the fire starter those were like
absolutely critical tools for survival
and for day to day functioning so we
finally got our fire
we can cook our food we can purify our
water
we can make tools we could signal
we could stay warm
we could stay alive
i've survived in the urban environment
my whole life to be able to go into
nature and create something that you
need
that's invaluable
i mean you can't buy that
if the world came to an end and
civilization collapsed i do feel
confident that there is a sufficient
number of people out there today that
are doing and practicing these things
that civilization will arise again
[Music]
christopher our experts in disaster
preparedness practical preppers feel
your extremely well-rounded and survival
skills
and gathering wild resources would prove
invaluable if the big one were to hit la
however
although you are able to live off the
land
you must accept the possibility that
during an earthquake the wild areas in
l.a may quickly become depleted i
completely agree
we recommend that you store more food to
prepare for this possibility
i would tend to agree
that you can never have enough you
should always have more water than you
think is sufficient
and you should always have more food
than you think is sufficient also in a
true crisis situation you will be well
served to carry guns for your protection
and choose a safe bug out location in
advance that could be used as a
fortified base
he actually does not know what possible
plan i do have like that but
it's a valid point and i am in complete
agreement thank you
[Music]
so now that
okay so now that national geographic has
been here what have i done differently
well i have looked at what i store and
what i do and i have tried to make a few
minor adjustments but i look at the
skills that i try to develop and the
friendships that i try to cultivate and
i feel that those are key areas that are
always in need of development for long
term survival i get out there and work
to create the kind of society that you
really want to be a part of
and i feel that's what i have done
as a result of this national geographic
visit
next
houston party girl megan hurwitz
prepares for a worldwide oil crisis that
she believes will devastate the entire
nation
megan hurwit is a young uninhibited
independent woman living in houston
texas
she is a web developer who loves her
cats
her convertible
and her cocktails with friends
and
[Music]
i'm preparing for a catastrophic oil
crisis and when it hits the fan i'm
gonna be fitter than you are
i love houston i've always been a big
fan of our city skyline good eats and
good drinks i like to drink i like to
have fun with my friends i like to go
out
to the world may it not end but if it
does we're prepared
i also believe that we're going to have
an oil crisis in my lifetime
the united states is the largest
consumer of oil in the world and megan
believes that when an oil crisis occurs
the united states oil reserves will be
quickly used up
oils used to make a lot of the products
that we use today
it's used to power our cars and to power
the 18 wheelers that take us food
if the middle eastern countries suddenly
cut us off for gas
we would be very very quickly in trouble
houston scott's just about three-day
supply of everything including oil and
food all of that would go off the
shelves almost immediately
megan fears a global oil crisis will
hurl the country and her city into chaos
in a matter of
days we're gonna starve
that's going to send everybody into a
panic
they're going to run out to all the
supermarkets and buy up everything that
you need to survive
people are going to start stealing other
people's food you're gonna hear gunshots
a lot of them people are gonna start to
kill each other when people's kids go
hungry they're gonna come after you
your lives would be in danger my life
would be in danger and it would happen
within a matter of days
megan lives in a 700 square foot
apartment
which makes prepping for long-term
survival a challenge
there are so many problems prepping in a
tiny little urban apartment we have no
space for preps we've had to fill up
every nook and cranny with canned goods
and water we've had to dedicate a lot of
space in our second bedroom
we've got mres
most likely this will feed me for three
months i have a veggie bank and an herb
bank it's important to have seats
because if the stuff really hits the fan
you're not gonna have any way of
buying food
these are the safes
this one's for smaller handguns and
pistols this one's for full rifles
i've got guns bullets lots of bullets
lots of bullets
i used to be a lot more shallow i still
love high heels and i love fashion but
i'm also thinking about is there
anything that i can conceal a weapon in
is there anything that i can hook a
harness to is there anything that i can
store a gun case in
i plan to bug in anywhere from two to
four weeks in this apartment have my
preps that i have here to feed myself
and to keep myself hydrated wait for
everybody to panic and leave and then
bug out as soon as everybody's left i'll
be walking out of houston to a bug-out
vehicle an undisclosed location
i'm going to mexico
survival kitty wants to be cute that's
his plan of survival unfortunately cats
are not as useful as dogs when it comes
to survival situation my boyfriend's
plan for the kitty cats if the fan is to
put a bullet in their head
they had a good life we've spoiled them
rotten and he insists that once we get
to the bug out location we'll
we'll take more in
sorry timber
right there right in the brain stem
i've only been called crazy for prepping
once but she was really malicious about
it but you know what when it hits the
fan she's gonna starve to death and i'm
gonna go
expecting a middle east oil shutdown
megan has devised a way to evacuate
houston
but how will she hold up in a real-time
bug-out simulation i think that was one
of the mistakes that i made this time
and what will the experts ultimately say
about her urban survival strategy
megan hurwitz is a vibrant 20-something
who spends her spare time taking full
advantage of houston's nightlife she is
also preparing for a global energy
catastrophe that she fears will cause
complete chaos
which will make bugging out her only
chance at survival
bugging out basically means taking the
goods that you need to survive putting
them in a backpack and walking out on
foot this is my go bag
my go bag has 24 hours worth of preps
that i keep on me at all times it's
really easy to carry around it's very
inconspicuous it's meant for an
emergency situation where i will be
coming back home feminine products are
really important to keep spares of i
keep pictures of my social security card
my driver's license my passport and
birth control right now we have 160
condoms
so it'll it'll last us you know four or
five days
this is my inch bag an inch bag stands
for i'm not coming home
and it carries everything that i would
need in order to survive
long enough to get to my bug out vehicle
the great thing about this bag is that
it carries a lot of stuff but one of the
deterrents is that it's extremely
obvious this bag would be saying please
mug me take my stuff and leave me for
dead
megan believes that the crippling
economic effects of an oil crisis will
increase crime exponentially
today she goes shopping for a bug out
bag that might reduce her risk of
becoming a statistic
i'm looking for a better bug out
bag i need something a little bit more
discreet than a camping bag i'm
preparing for the worst as we all should
and so i'm looking for something with an
external frame that i can hook bags to
so i can carry untraditional shape gear
this particular unit as you can see
it hides everything that identifies it
as a backpack it goes within the ceiling
compartment
then it looks like a regular out of
share or regular
as i mean instead of you carrying it
like that when you do get to the point
that you have to have so much overweight
and expansion within the bag
and you can barely easily convert it
into a bag i want one of those okay
like you have no other stuff on you
what's the one thing that you would need
pepper spray is probably the easiest
thing that a lot of women will carry
think of this the adrenaline is flowing
but guess what
it's not flowing in you until you're
touched it's already flowing once you've
been contained or held then the scenario
changes you're going to have to have the
mindset if it ever happens i'm going to
survive
i have some skills that i can trade i
have some useful preps that i can trade
and i think that i would survive on my
feet for uh three or four months before
i'd have to resort to less than savory
means of supporting myself
you don't want to end up having to [ __ ]
yourself out in order to live and really
that's what a lot of women would face
megan plans to escape houston by hiking
out of the city with her 40-pound inch
bag in preparation she works out four
hours a day six days a week to make sure
she will be able to complete the journey
when the oil runs out the cars won't
work the planes won't fly the trucks
won't drive
and i'm a
machine i have to make every part of me
work at peak efficiency i'm preparing
for a time when i might have to fight my
way out of the city
i'm gonna have to do a lot of climbing
up and down buildings
trying to get away
evasive maneuvers
so uh it's good for the ankles to kind
of practice up you don't want to snap
one when you're doing your actual bug
out because there's not going to be
anyone to help you
and you're going to run into people who
may have nefarious purposes
megan will need more than just brute
strength to survive
today she works with survival specialist
larry phelan to learn important skills
megan came to me today to learn more
about survival if she has any problems
with you know the upcoming issues with
the collapse of our society or whatever
what can i do exactly if i lose my knife
a knife is very easily made with a rock
the edge
wow break those off like that and clean
your fish
so right now i'm following along the
vertebrae don't head that way too much
you got to get down until you get the
right spot there you can feel that bone
touching your rock
cooking the fish will actually decrease
the amount of nutrients and the calories
that you're going to get so eating it
raw is actually preferable and i'm about
to do that
fishy but very very very fresh
if chaos engulfs houston as megan
believes she feels she needs additional
security which one you're shooting at
when the hits the fan
don't be the one standing in front of
the fan
you better be prepared to defend
yourself
any specific tips for how to deal with
the situation as a woman you just have
to make sure that they hear authority in
your voice you want to make sure they
understand that i am not your average
moment i will pop a cap in your ass and
you're not taking my nice
the ar is a good choice for her you're
gonna have a hard time beating this gun
for fighting people
one of my biggest issues is that i have
trouble loading the magazines quickly
give it a spank
in a combat situation that would
actually really slow me down and be a
detriment to me well and that's why you
need to darn sure practice that
the ar-15 is my favorite
i sure as hell wouldn't want you
shooting at me
[Music]
megan is prepping for a catastrophic
global oil crisis that she believes will
occur in her lifetime but when she is
faced with a practice bug out will she
be truly prepared
and what will the experts practical
preppers think of her preparations and
her evacuation plan this pack's getting
pretty heavy
megan hurwitz is preparing for a global
oil crisis which she believes will lead
to a total breakdown of civilization
this party girl turned prepper practices
shooting regularly just put the gun up
and does intense workouts
in the event of an oil shutdown megan
fears that all motorized transportation
will be useless making the 50 000 miles
of houston roadways
a giant parking lot
she believes her only chance to escape
to safety
is on foot
bye kitties behave yourself
tonight all of megan's preps and
training will be put to the ultimate
test a practice run of her on foot
evacuation plan
it's gonna be 10 to 12 miles depending
upon what i have to go around and what
obstacles i'm gonna have to travel
through
the best time to do this would be right
at dusk that way i'll have enough cover
of darkness
but i'll still be able to see
there's a good chance there won't be any
power so i'll be
completely in the dark for the most part
i'll be starting from the heights and
making my way down montrose
and straight through the city
if i hurry i can be there in three hours
if there's blockades he could take me
all the way to four or five
when i do this for real
all this is gonna be dark
there's a few areas that i walk through
that uh are not the most savory
there were a few points when i thought i
might need to pull out my handgun
some of the sketchy errors i was a
little worried about getting mugged
it's happened to me before it could
happen again
i could handle myself
from here we're gonna head out of the
city
until i reach my bug-out vehicle and
then i'll be able to drive to my bug out
location
i'm about six miles from my final
destination
and i've covered about six miles of
ground you do
you should always carry spare pair on
you
kind of getting tired
ah this pack's getting a little heavy
my feet feel like they're about to fall
off my ankles
so it's been a long
long six hours
hike uh took twice as long as i thought
it was going to i'm just going to
continue to follow
the brook out of town in a real bug-out
situation it's best to follow the sewer
lines and the rivers because they're
inconspicuous
there's a somewhat fresh stream of water
that can be purified
it's usually below the water table it's
away from the streets it's really the
best way to go
i think next time i'm going to carry
less gear maybe i can invest in some
lighter
lighter gear
when you're doing
a real bug out you want to be carrying
in ounces not pounds and i think that
was one of the mistakes that i made this
time
all right i'm exhausted but i'm losing
time and i'm almost there
not much further
i'm by no means an expert at any of this
stuff
even with all the preparation and all
the skill sets i'm trying to learn and
all the foresight that i'm putting into
prepping to hit the fan next week i
probably wouldn't make it if it hits the
fan in five years i'll probably be okay
megan
if as you predicted there's a global oil
crisis in your lifetime
the experts practical preppers feel that
your food and water storage will leave
you woefully unprepared to remain in
your apartment for any length of time
that's about all we can afford
and your plan to leave houston will be
your only alternative
improving your self-defense skills and
physical conditioning and having a
prepped out bag are all important steps
however
you should have at least two alternative
routes i believe i have a smart route
for evacuating the city but i haven't
given much thought to a secondary or
tertiary plan that's something that i'll
be looking into very shortly
also the experts review estimates that
your bug out vehicle has only enough gas
to take you 300 miles
at a minimum mexico is 320 miles from
houston the experts advise that you
store additional fuel in your vehicle or
have hidden caches along the way i may
not have enough gas to complete the
journey but i believe that there are
opportunities to acquire trade for it
along the way
since national geographic has left
i enlisted myself in the us military
in the hopes that i would be able to
help
my fellow civilians if times were to
grow darker than they are now
and i've actually completely revisited
our bug out location i don't think i
want to head down to mexico because of
the
violence that's prevalent in that area
my advice to people is get it together
because
anything could happen
how likely are the events featured in
this program
the earth's magnetic poles swap about
every four hundred thousand years but
there is no evidence that a swap is due
soon and it wouldn't impact the earth's
tilt rotation or seismic activity there
has never been a complete cutoff of
foreign oil to the united states and
it's not likely
top importers are allies canada and
mexico also the u.s produces about half
the oil it consumes and it has more than
a month's supply in the world's largest
government stockpile
and the possibility of a major
earthquake a magnitude 8.0 or higher
could hit los angeles in the next 30
years but the chances are less than 3
percent
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
you